rund 1900 vulkane gibt es wohl auf der
erde und da sind die in den ozean noch
nicht mehr mitgezählt mindestens genau
so viele gibt es alleine auf dem
planeten venus und viele weitere auch
auf unseren anderen nachbar planeten was
wissen wir über die vulkane auf anderen
planeten und inwieweit geben sie
hinweise auf außerirdisches leben
herzlich willkommen bei pixum science
fiction und vielen dank für den
themenvorschlag auf whatsapp und in anna
messengern wirklich ein sehr spannendes
thema nämlich 120 kilometer hoch war die
rauchfahne später es stand genau an
dieser stelle ein dunkler fleck mit
einem durchmesser von sage und schreibe
400 kilometern die rede ist von einem
vulkanausbruch auf dem jupitermond io
der gigantische landstriche verändert
hat ist wohl einer der vulkanisch
aktivsten die stirn im sonnensystem die
amerikanische raumsonde galileo hatte im
jahr 2000 diese bilder möglich gemacht
aber dieser ausbruch war nur einer von
vielen auf dem mond des jupiters schon
seit 1979 hatte die raumsonde voyager1
aufnahmen gemacht die beweisen dass ihr
vulkanisch aktiv ist hervorgerufen durch
gezeitenkräfte die der große jupiter auf
seinen kleinen trabanten auswirkt diese
heizen ihm auf und kneten ihn gnadenlos
durch vulkanausbrüche auf anderen
planeten unseres weltalls sind
tatsächlich nicht mit denen auf unserer
erde zu vergleichen lavafontänen steigen
bei uns maximal einen kilometer in den
himmel hinauf auf dagegen ist die
schwerkraft kleiner und auch die
fehlende atmosphäre trägt dazu bei dass
die lava fetzen sehr viel höher kommen
die vulkane spucken die brodelnde masse
weit ins all hinaus zudem handelt es
sich bei canis muss auf anderen planeten
nicht immer nur um lava vulkane sondern
es gibt auch andere arten wie eisvulkane
beispielsweise forschungsteams weltweit
begannen mit ihren untersuchungen zu
wirken im all
etwa ab den 70er jahren als das apollo
team vulkanische steine mit von seiner
expedition brach der mars hat wohl den
gigantischen schild vulkan im gesamten
sonnensystem mehr als 20 kilometer ist
olympus mons in die höhe
erreicht er sein durchmesser erreicht an
die 600 kilometer schild vulkan
entstehen wenn sich mehrere lavaströme
übereinander lagern nach schätzungen ist
der gigantisch zum vulkan in die
menschheit kennt wohl vor etwa einer
milliarde jahren entstanden und hatte
vor 220 millionen jahren die letzte
eruption weil der mas kleiner ist als
die erde beträgt die kavitation hier
auch nur etwa ein drittel
so stieg die man das manchmal wohl
schneller auf und zwar es leichter und
schneller weiter er gehört zu einer
ganzen vulkan provinz auf dem mars die
etwa so groß ist wie ganz europa ist im
vergangenen sommer hatte ein
forschungsteam aus tschechien an gebiet
mit weiteren 130 kleinen vulkan entdeckt
und zwar mit der hilfe der nasa
raumsonde mars reconnaissance orbiter
eine besonders große überraschung war
dabei das alter der vulkane von gerade
einmal 200 bis 400 millionen jahren
zudem fanden sie mit einem spektrometer
tatsächlich hinweise darauf dass dort
auch einmal außerirdisches leben
existiert haben könnte
konkret fanden sie mineral mit viel
silizium teilweise waren auch opal
artige substanzen fahren diese
zusammensetzung deutet darauf hin dass
mineral aus heißen lösungen ausgefallen
und mineralisiert wurden also eine warme
mineralreiche und energie spendende
umgebung perfekt also als lebensraum für
mikroorganismen die gegen soll jetzt
noch weiter auf 1 vorhandenes leben auf
dem mars untersucht werden
auf der venus dagegen ist der so
genannte hot spot vulkanismus zu finden
also gebiete mit einer aktiven großen
unterirdischen magma kammer 2015 sein
forschungsteam der esa überzeugende
hinweise darauf dass die venus auch
heute noch vulkanisch aktiv ist eine
heiße und dichte wolke schicht hatte das
bis dahin verborgen gehalten doch der
infrarotdetektoren der esa raumsonde
venus express konnte mehrere hotspots
aufspüren die eine auffallend erhöhte
temperatur aufweisen und zwar in bereits
bekannten vulkan regionen auf der venus
die vermutung der wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen frische aber
bereits erstarrte lavaströme außerdem
konnten schwankende schwefeldioxid werte
in der atmosphäre entdeckt werden
auch das lässt auf aktiv
vulkanismus schließen dazu hakans wtm
einer der beteiligten esa forscher
unsere studie zeigt dass die venus unser
nächster nachbar noch heute aktiv ist
und sich verändert das ist ein wichtiger
schritt auf unsere erforschung der
geschichte dieses und unseres planeten
allerdings werden hier offene lavaflüsse
vermittelt und keine ausbrüche wie bei
uns auf der erde die lager soll demnach
leicht und flüssig aus der venus
oberfläche heraustreten und dann windet
wieder unter die küste zurück strömen
wie bei uns ganz einfache flüsse bis zu
mehreren hundert kilometern sollen die
lavaströme dort lang sein wenn er kein
video dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollen dann endet mich darum
geht ihr die etwas unzuverlässiger cobox
sie auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein
video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von
mir persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach drauf kriegen und am
besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks
um social media abonnieren da gibt es
das neueste aus der social media welt
dafür hier klicken
da klicken dann klicken aber nicht die
genau die leute vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
supervulkan wird ausbrechen bis dann